- [Kelly] You're from the south,
obviously.
- Yes.
- I love your accent so much.
- Where are you from?
- I'm from Fort Worth, Texas.
- Oh okay.
- Yeah, yeah.
Well, Fort Worth and
Burleson both, but in Texas.
- A lot of people think I'm
from Texas, but I'm not.
I'm from South Carolina.
- I love South Carolina.
- Yeah, it's nice.
- Yeah.
- It's beautiful.
So did you grow up with, I
heard, a bit of a potty mouth?
- I didn't grow up with a potty mouth.
I became.
- When did it happen?
- In my mature years.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I became very dirty, just horrible.
And I was relieved to
hear that you do that.
- Yeah.
- Because to me you seem
sort of angelic and pure.
- You know what, that's so nice.
Don't you laugh, Weiss.
(Andy laughs)
Weiss has known me for like over a decade.
- But that's your image, you know?
- No, no, I am that, but I just,
I also was a cocktail waitress
and "darn it" just doesn't cover it.
It doesn't cover the ground.
- Dag gummit.
- Yeah, that doesn't cover it.
- No.
- My mom's not excited
about it, but it just, yeah,
it's still here.
It just feels good to say
(beep) sometimes, you know.
(audience laughing)
- But, can you?
What do you do on daytime?
Do you bleep it?
- They edit that out or bleep.
I don't know what they're gonna do.
I'll probably lose viewers,
but I'll gain a whole new kind
of audience, so it's fine.
But no, but sometimes.
- I relate to this.
I relate relate to this.
- Yes.
Speaking of that.
- Can say the words I really like?
- Go for it.
Yes, yes.
- I did say, I mean, rat's ass I can.
I don't give a rat's ass.
- Rat's ass.
- I don't give a rat's ass.
- That's southern.
- I had a friend who used to say that.
She's such a classy lady
that I thought, you know, that's cool.
I say that.
- We're covered.
- I'm terrible because I say (beep) a lot.
- Me too.
(Andy laughs)
'Cause it feels good.
But I do feel like we're safe
because I don't even know
if she wants everybody
to know this, but Dolly
Parton is like, okay,
she's like the most perfect
person on the planet.
I love Dolly Parton.
She's the nicest human ever.
Amazing, but kind of a sailor.
- I love that.
- Like a bit of a sailor
and it made me feel good.
- That I have anything in common with her,
just makes me.
- Exactly.
- Particularly this area,
I feel okay about it.
- I know, I feel like if she's doing it
and she's like so
beloved, it's, we're fine.
- Yeah, we're good.
- Yeah.